The Joe Rogan Experience you see the
lady that got duct tape on a flight
great they duct taped their face very
funny that's wild yeah they run a frat
in the sky
to get your face ducted you got to be
saying some crazy [ __ ] but they're like
dude [ __ ] duct taper what is she
doing oh [ __ ] I did it like The
Sopranos it's just like takes hot takes
I I'll say it right now Brian Cranston
wasn't that great and Breaking Bad
everyone's like
yeah it's you got to be an obnoxious
[ __ ] to get duct taped I want to know
what they said she said yeah anybody
else duct tape your mouth if you hear
that please reach out to us am I
imagining that they duct tape her mouth
or did they really duct tape her mouth
damn dude did she Sue I don't know man I
think she's in trouble I think woman
look at this she got fined 82 000 damn
woman duct taped aboard American
Airlines flight faces record 82 000
oh yeah she tried to go for the door
dude
so the FAA is going to find her but does
that
is that for sure the woman assaulted and
bit a flight attendant after she
attempted to open the forward boarding
door oh [ __ ] okay we restrained for the
safety and the security of other
customers and our crew oh my God damn
dude someone going for the door so she
bit somebody that's why they mouth did
her mouth she could be heard screaming
you you you at passengers filling uh
filing pastors flight attendants calmly
nodded their goodbyes
oh wow so she's screaming at them oh it
wasn't in the air though okay oh it
wasn't no I think they were like they
were grounded oh they were on the way to
fly which almost is like so before they
even got in the air they're grounded and
they duct taped her you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
duct taper when she was on the ground
that's the best part of they should lead
with that oh here it is agency said she
attempted to hug and kiss another
passenger tried to exit the plane
mid-flight oh she was in the flight oh
okay all right she tried the eggs at the
plane mid-fly and bit another flyer
multiple times before the cube with the
crew restrainer
yeah it's a different lady against the
woman that says I think I propose to
find the second largest ever against a
woman on a Delta flight okay so it's a
different flight so duct tape lady
wasn't the lady from Las Vegas to
Atlanta okay so this is a second flight
oh I see okay the so this one this is
only 2021. she's biting people we're
setting new records there's another
story where there is like uh the duct
taping has it's been happening to
multiple happened to uh there's a while
that happened but she was talking [ __ ]
like what they just duct tape people now
yeah dude and then you're in Sigma Chi
that's how it happens what did they do
to them if that was the lady that was on
the ground that got duct taped like that
so if the other story was another person
that bit a bunch of people yeah what
what did this lady do that they didn't
just remember mover from the plane they
just said no [ __ ] you're staying here
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] fly if it's on
the ground that sounds so insane just
pop the door open and get her the [ __ ]
out yeah you open the door you call the
cops they get her out like they duct
tape don't have to fly this lady here it
makes no sense
is that are we right here yeah she was
saying yeah she was I think she was just
[ __ ] crazy oh my God can you use that
excuse anymore was she just [ __ ] well
there's there's levels to that okay and
don't be ableist then I'm sorry I'm
sorry shades of crazy duct taped video
shows woman duct tape deceit after
trying to open airplane door and
apparently this is great this I love the
post covering their ass and apparently
unhinged woman you know she's just
apparently that's a cute thing right
there she's [ __ ] tape to it that is
wild as everyone's getting off would you
keep filming her like would you sit
right in front of her and try to Goat
her like you would a zombie like if you
saw a zombie yeah and if there was a
zombie that was chained up in someone's
basement yeah and uh I'll be like holy
[ __ ] it's a real zombie I mean look at
that [ __ ] what I want to see I shown
those dead teeth I knew the zombie could
not break free you sure he can't break
free I might get close to him I'd be
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] Beat it yeah I might
be thinking
so if you were on this flight yeah would
you like just put the camera in front of
her and not say anything I would
honestly think of I would I would think
of yeah I would think of something fun
to say I would want a good parting right
yeah you know what I mean it seems like
you'd want to focus on her for a few
seconds according to this person here's
the scene if you it's okay it sounds
kind of crazy two-hour flight July 6
from Dallas Fort Worth and to Charlotte
North Carolina have been delayed for at
least three hours before it finally
departed at midnight but about an hour
into the trip chaos broke out uh this
woman said that in a subsequent video
describing the hectic scene flight
attendants began turning on the lights
around 1 30 a.m she said and we see all
flight attendants running up and down
the aisles frantically kind of like
whispering to each other the planes crew
began locking bathrooms grabbing bags
from overhead bins and wouldn't say what
was happening it was just kind of like
chaos and no one knows what's going on
she continued finally the pilot spoke
over the intercom asking people to stay
in their seats referencing to a bad
situation in the plane right now
according to the passenger then we're
gradually starting to hear more and more
screaming and we're like wait a minute
she noted
just as the plane was about to land a
flight attendant who sat near them
explained that a woman with an apparent
mental issue had an outburst like had
the urge to get off the plane and she
was saying I need to get off this plane
and she went up to the exits and started
banging on the doors saying you need to
let me off this plane oh I guess it took
five flight attendants to subdue her and
like literally take her down so she said
of the incident which was first reported
by TMC they pretty much took her down
put her in the seat and duct taped her
damn dude if you're what they don't talk
about is the first guy that noticed
she's not telling people what she's
doing so someone's got guns up to the
door someone's got to notice it oh my
God and you're just reading your
magazine and you're like
has anybody ever opened up one of those
doors I don't know that's a I mean
that's gonna suck everyone out right
that would just be a I wonder how easy
it is to do probably not that easy
because they always talk about the
weight of the door and you got the
pressure of being in the sky I wonder if
you can open it while the plane's moving
like I wonder if there's some fail safes
well
I hate going with like the impossibility
and being like you can't do it but
according it's physically impossible to
open a door mid-flight well what if you
like Thor Thor what if you're her son of
Odin what if you're like Eddie Hall like
one of those gigantic power lifters
strongman dudes yeah cruising altitude I
should say okay so up at like 30 000
feet impossible that's a airplane
according to this Business Insider which
you know best best source for this
information yeah they're Aviation
airplane doors are impossible to open at
cruising altitude which is about 36 000
feet pressurization mimic conditions at
8 000 feet above sea level to keep
passengers imagine having the balls
to like know that uh this person you're
traveling with is completely insane like
maybe you're dating this lady and she's
like I Gotta Get Off This Plane I've
Gotta Get Off This Plane she runs to the
door but you know the physics yeah so
you just go again
you're just doing a boyfriend in an
argument thing yeah kick in the door in
the middle of the flight do you wanna
let's let's drive smart can we talk
about this or are you going to try to
open the do you think maybe that's
selfish to the other [ __ ] people on
the plane that you just want to fly to
the ground and everybody else has to the
guy behind you is going hey don't prove
nothing don't get her get your girl
what's going on don't prove nothing
what the [ __ ] are you doing oh my God
yeah that would be terrifying to witness
because again you don't know how strong
this [ __ ]
people are crazy they're really strong
they rip their arms apart trying to do
something dude if she did a bump a PCP
before that plane took off and then it
was like I'm gonna start cooking at 30
000. my boxing coach got his finger
bitten off on PCP and had it replaced
with his toe what which toe his second
toe
his index finger and he had it curved
permanently so he could throw right
hooks
wait so his hand just looks like when he
shook his hand he had he he had this
going on so it's like a toe he never
really like shook his he shook his hand
but you got a finger in there so the toe
is this part yes the toe was this part
so but it was permanently bent so you
could pinch things with it right but it
was a terminally bat it didn't
straighten out it was like this but you
could do you could do most of the things
you could do if you had a finger there
but he got it bitten off in a street
fight while he was on PCP well he was on
PC yes that's why I walked away oh my
God okay
um after the cargo door tore off in
Flight caused an explosive decompression
and ejecting nine people from the plane
oh my God damn that was an 89. I
remember that damn there was a flight
and the people just got sucked out of
the plane in mid-flight that was a
Hawaii fright right going to Honolulu
yeah that's it oh my God that's so scary
man that [ __ ] that always scared me
when I saw it in movies whenever they
show that they show the person
[Music]
Wild Wings yeah bro but also if you're
ready for it you could do some cool
poses on the way out you could Superman
your brain would be flooded yeah with
psychic chemicals because you would
absolutely 100 know you're going to die
there's no way you're going to survive
and you would probably get a golden
geometric pattern that opens up and
takes you straight to the afterlife yeah
you just come and [ __ ] at the same time
your body's like let it all yeah and you
just pass through and you pop on the
other side like on impact dude and in
reality it just looks like a jelly
sandwich hit the ground whoever's near
you they never talk about those those
people that watch people land yeah
you're just like oh it's coming through
the air it's not good or yeah
splattering